coronavirus is bad enough so here's the
question why would anyone want to make
out that it's worse than it is America
is the largest coronavirus disaster in
the world by a million miles all right a
million miles to try and prove that
claim she showed this graphic of cases
without helpful little red arrow to show
you just how bad America is looks really
bad right just the worst but America's
population is bigger than all those
countries put together even the New York
Times isn't that deceptive they said a
better comparison is with western
continental Europe and on that basis it
turns out there are many thousands more
cases in countries not run by drop but
even that's not the whole picture
because the number of cases statistic
actually measures the number of tests so
why don't we compare what really matters
how many lives are being lost there's
the actual data Johns Hopkins deaths per
100,000 America has the least bad
outbreak of any major country apart from
Germany and as some have noted if you
take the New York metro area out of it
the rest of America is close to Germany
the media's other constant apocalyptic
course is about testing just shows how
far we are behind in terms of testing
and Tracy
behind who we test more than anywhere
else by far over eight million test to
date it's not even close on test per
population we're ahead of South Korea
who the media constantly go on about as
the gold standard and by the way that's
after the initial bungling by the
media's precious public sector CDC was
replaced by the private sector
innovation brought in by the president
and his team is not just testing though
the fear mongers in the East Coast media
elite after weeks of solipsistic Lee
assuming their experience in New York
was the same as everyone else's and now
trying to frighten the rest of America
with misinformation about the coming
coronavirus disaster in places like a
packing plant in Sioux Falls South
Dakota South Dakota South Dakota South
Dakota governor Kristi Noem still
refuses to issue stay-at-home orders
South Dakota gives us a good window into
what could happen the governor there
didn't put into effect a stay-at-home
order I don't think they've ever paid so
much attention to red state America in
their lives but now they can terrify
people about the looming disease
apocalypse for the meatpacking rubes
they're all in but I checked the data on
the deadliest coronavirus day in South
Dakota five people died five family
tragedies but the number was five that's
per 100,000 in South Dakota four in New
York it's a hundred and thirty-eight we
put them on a chart but you can barely
even see South Dakota
we're still waiting for the media South
Dakota apocalypse it's non-stop
fear-mongering misinformation they said
the new head of the HHS coronavirus
response team was a labradoodle breeder
a labradoodle breeder is currently
running the day-to-day
federal government response to a
once-in-a-century pandemic at HHS
frightening right I mean what an utterly
competent federal government putting a
dog breeder in charge of coronavirus
except he's not just a dog breeder he
turns out once you check the facts to be
an experienced government official in
multiple administration's including in
the White House and the health
department but whatever let's just scare
the American people let's just scare
them about nursing homes too we have to
be able to go into hot spots or
potential hot spots like nursing homes
or prisons or densely populated
neighborhoods and be able to test people
who aren't showing symptoms yes two
weeks before you said that dr. Burke
said this will be doing Sentinel
surveillance throughout nursing homes
throughout inner-city federal clinics
throughout indigenous populations to
really be able to find early alerts of
asymptomatic individuals in the
community the worst disaster in the
world that coming disaster in South
Dakota the government's doing nothing on
and on it goes but it's all a
misinformation and it matters because
Democrat leaders take their cue from
what they see on their favorite news
outlets CNN MSNBC all the rest of them
it's a mutual appreciation society
thank you for your reporting on this
story you've done a tremendous service
to us all any chance I get a woman thank
you for the beautiful presentation you
make about the challenge that our
country is under tell me oh yes thank
you thank you so much you're so
marvelous this misinformation this
fear-based oak it's not just empty words
it has a real-world impact the human
cost of the shutdown pushed by the
shutdown fanatics on TV if you want to
open up they say you want people to die
he's a fan of money first mortality
second as the president fiddles
people are dying the president is now
listening to voices on the right that's
a really what's a million seniors when
you're thinking about the whole economy
ignore the grotesque and gratuitous
insult and just focus on the facts it's
not just coronavirus that kills the
shutdown costs lives too
who senior cadets at the Air Force
Academy committed suicide within days of
each other after they were isolated Zach
Branson's liver transplant was cancelled
when he might just have a month to live
Alison Krupnick was set for cancer
surgery before her Hospital called it
off in April one point four million
healthcare jobs disappeared the fear
stoked by the establishment media
according to this doctor has literally
killed people my hunch is that it may be
a good third of the toll of people dying
out of the hospital maybe because of
preventable illnesses that are not the
direct result of the virus but actually
in direct result of people being fearful
about getting care people are choosing
to stay away we even found that for
stroke and even some of our heart
attacks and just listen to this doctor
I'm calling as a clinical psychologist
our percentage of death is way less than
0.01 percent our percentage of getting
it is a little bit higher but not much
and we're watching as many counties are
the emotional toll that this virus is
taking on people with rising incidences
of domestic violence child abuse and
just the emotional devastation heart
attack stroke child abuse but you know
we've got to keep going with a shutdown
have your heart attack at home I'm sure
you'll be fine
how bad is a stroke really do you need a
doctor for that child abuse it's a price
worth paying
here's the real intellectual dishonesty
of the fear mongers they don't even ask
whether the human cost of the shot down
is worth pain because they pretend there
isn't one stopping coronavirus
infections is the only and absolute
imperative nothing else matters
this is what Santa Clara County Health
Officer dr. Sarah Cody said recently she
imposed the nation's first shot down
here in the Bay Area if we lift too soon
there's no reason to think we wouldn't
have exponential spread our whole
population is susceptible and at risk
that is not true
we know from their data that over 80% of
those infected have mild or zero
symptoms our whole
population is not at risk because of
this reckless manufactured climate of
fear people are terrified of even
catching this virus that's ridiculous as
we've said here from the start the focus
should be on protecting the vulnerable
but no they pushed fear and we now have
a human catastrophe from the shock town
millions upon millions have lost their
jobs their health insurance their hope
most of them by the way the exact same
people the moralizing media grandstand
as say they speak for guess who's been
hurt most by this shot down Hispanic
Americans turns out their biggest threat
wasn't from their racist Trump but you
the fear mongering media your
misinformation has a human cost it
breeds fear fear stops people going to
the hospital even when there are empty
bed fear stops people going out even
when they're not at risk
fear costs jobs and livelihoods yes but
it also costs lives so please stop this
dangerous divisive misinformation
I'll give the last word to someone I
don't know but who seems incredibly
smart and brilliant at what she does if
somebody is repeatedly miss informing
the American public about important
things having to do with this disease
don't broadcast that tell us what you
think about all of that
that's deep Hilton X and that next Rev s
fnc and share it when we post it